in munchies news submit if I Love You
Jay
happy face uh Julia maybe I don't know
or Jojo see it's only you tooth Buffy
are you deal with the day G so a food
blogger has unveiled a new weird and
wonderful doughnut hybrid made using
fried ramen noodles ill donuts with
fried ramen hello Nina leave the [__]
fried ramen [__] out of the equation
sounds dumb everything we is fried ramen
right now sure oh don't oh yeah yeah the
churros the [__] ice cream in the
middle of that makes sense
that is delicious ramen donuts this is
called a ran nut man that could not have
named it anything worse I've been
[__] horrible random mountain and it
was created by 21 year old UCLA student
named Josh Josh zero sales so far no
we're talking about I don't want to
knock the idea I just want to try it
first and then I'll judge cuz your
picture yeah
you should make ramen that tastes like
donut not ramens
that are donuts alright don't it at
least like Robin no no no do you know if
it's sweet julia Romanick you should
describe it no it's I think that's a
restart my computer your browser
yeah my browser it's all that porno
won't have too much point Tommy's been
boring you're like I know mommy week me
alright so here's some photos it doesn't
look bad it actually looks kind of good
yeah yeah take a look
so you got the jelly-filled you look you
got the Homer Simpson so the batter is
made out of ramen noodles mm-hmm but it
doesn't like I don't know you know
usually when you see something it
produces a flavor in your mouth when I
look at that it doesn't produce the
right flavors in my mouth like if this I
don't know if my mouth isn't matching my
imagination with my eyes I'm just
imagining savory stuff but Oh cuz it's
ramen - ramen is it savory oh I just got
an idea
I mean maybe sweet and Siri you know
that mango sticky rice from the Thai
restaurant Oh get the sticky rice Oh fry
that [__] mmm someone's gonna take my
[__] idea gotcha share that yeah oh
my god what you sure they have that
already
where Thai they have tired dishes
there's this fried sticky rice thing
five sticky rice balls and the Thai
cuisine this is rice sticky rice in a
pancake being inventive than Vietnam
which is kind of it doesn't taste as
sweet I think I just gave out a genius
idea what exists right isn't the Thai
cuisine
yeah but nobody did it a doughnut stop
not a dollar stuff all right take that
like a free bonus Oh are we able to
actually take this is it anywhere near
LA he's from UCLA yeah okay Felix does
know about so boilers dorm room in y'all
stack of them know about this brand nut
I guess I'm so weird ram net brand know
it sounds dumb so it's made with instant
ramen noodles all that has been cooked
in a special cinnamon spiced milk and
then mold it into a traditional donut
shape then stuffed with ice or like some
kinda like affectionate sugar
ingredients like I see me yeah like I
seem Jam custard yeah exactly like that
and they said that the flavor is similar
to like a rice pudding and a texture
like Google Google hey Yugi yeah I don't
even know what the hell that is
I never tried kugel not that I know of
you know I've tried a lot of like weird
ownage like super hybrid doughnuts
cronuts faux nuts freaking bones nuts
with mo nuts
trade business yeah honestly some of my
most favorite daughter is still just the
plain glazed door from Krispy Kremes
true sometimes specifically Krispy
Kremes yes those audiences met suppose
just nothing hits the spot like that one
I had to agree with my but for him he
actually puts his recipe on his block so
anyone who can make it oh what a
horrible businessman he's done it he's
done you could have [__] never went
to college ever again in your life so
you just all his free recipe every week
and do it let me guess he's now applying
for a master's degree even dumber well
maybe you guys are done maybe it was
already producing like 20 bucks per
click or some [__] and he's getting this
like advertising and now he's making a
lot of house blow up so much like who
said oh this is so good we start doing
this [__] have you been trying to make
it at home and it tastes as good as the
one that he made in his dorm room I
don't know if anyone has tried to make
it at home but he encourages those to
make it a little bit different from the
way that he makes it just because we'll
remove the Romans
yeah we're gonna make it with sticky
rice deep-fried let's try it I don't
even know where to kiss T I'd rather try
like a mochi donut or something best a
second in line did not my work you know
that [__] football at dim sum I don't
know what the [__] it's called but it's
like a meat dog yeah that's the model
[__] right there
it's got mochi and you [__]
deep-fried a [__] inside it's got meat
oh man savoury crunchy soft mmm new ways
to get [__] fat in creeper news
creepers creepers I committed by Kayla D
vampire famed trucker was recently
caught holding women hostage abusing
them and keeping them as sex slaves
murder yeah a trucker where was he
keeping them like in the truck
yeah something that how do they kidnap
them that is a good 18-wheeler shape
whatever sick some way I don't know good
cuz they just said that he was a truck
driver so it's like a 50 or 50 year old
man allegedly lured a woman into his
truck then for
so we altered their appearance and
ground down their teeth while holding
them prisoner from oh yeah so they can't
bite how did he lure them into the truck
were they prostitutes or no did he say
anything we just be friends them and
boot and likes you know like he'll like
be friends with the knife first and be
like hey you want to come on tonight I
want to see what in those Mackin hair I
got yeah what about mom
yeah exactly I mean like they have
examples here were telling to the Lambs
dude uh right here so says so like
victim D in 2000 or 2001 while she was
working at a retail store he contact her
again in 2005 and she agreed to join him
on a truck in his truck in Illinois for
what she expected to be a week and a
half he soon began beating her every day
prosecutors say and she came after two
and a half two and a half to two to
three months on the road so it's just
like so it's almost like he made friends
and like hey like you want to go on the
road with me for a week and in there
like I kind of like this guy yeah let's
do it
hey hop in and it's like mmm and then
one of the victims he was actually
married for two months with her before
he started doing all the [__] Willy
so he married whom he married one like
one of his victims and he just like I
can't take it I got a [__] torture
them yeah this guy I was after [__]
crazy yeah yeah no uh right now he is
arrested how many big ones have come
forward uh they're about like four
victims do you think maybe he had
something on them like yo I know your
mom's mom's mom and your kids and
everything all of this if you [__] go
to the cops they're all gonna disappear
maybe all of these women were um in a
relationship with him so they probably
felt guilty or it was their fault that
they down there
tea that's torture dude I mean that is
that is [__] weird but have you ever
heard of that I forgot what it was
called but when they become uh and not
in love with their cap the person that
captures them but they're so used to it
that they're dependent on them Stockholm
yeah yeah I forgot the name of it but
some of them are so so used to it that
they're like even in public they might
be walking with them but they don't even
run from them or like anything like that
yeah yeah I mean again it doesn't say
why they didn't go to the police it just
said that like a few of them like
escaped after two months of being held
hostage or whatnot and then like they
they just say like what exactly happened
we're like they were being with a belt
they were raped they were warned to not
look at each other but there were
multiple women
now like he he killed hostages oh maybe
they all left at the same time oh oh
don't look like he had one for two
months one for two years another one and
then the job as you know it's a thing
yeah and then if they all escaped at the
same time now I'm like oh that makes
sense
I don't know what is that because I was
able to escape no I mean thanks get that
different time zone oh I'm pretty sure
that they she had hostages overlapping
each other oh yeah yeah why he doesn't
yeah does it make sense as to why they
wouldn't go back if there's if they're
overlapping or whatever got away
like why wouldn't they go back and save
another girl's Geordie of women don't
report rape though yeah but then the
other females are captive with them they
should report that right hostage I'm
just I'm just thinking that there's so
many cases where women go through
certain things like this and they don't
report it yeah I mean honestly I wish I
can tell you guys why they didn't go to
the police but this article does not
completely say anything it just says
that like like these women they're
starting to slowly come up and starting
to say like you know like yeah this guy
did this to me this guy did this yeah I
did that because we're also thinking
about it from a very logical point of
view some people I think if they're in a
state of shock and like distress they
might not even have the courage to even
confront this guy or they just might
want to forget about anything that
happened and
I don't know there's so many
possibilities you know if there are any
of you out there was experiencing
[__] crazy [__] go straight to the
authorities please so we can put these
crazy people away before they harm
anybody else yeah so for this guy he
pleads not guilty to multiple counts of
kidnapping transporting for illegal such
activity and possession of child
pornography wow this guy's [__] and
he's been in the loose for so long
yeah and the article also says no
charges have been filed involving the
new incidents because the statute of
limitations have expired Oh where's the
next year so but but they want to
introduce these details as evidence to
make a case against him so his hearing
would be in December 17th but he is
already quite all the women are coming
up and he's pleading guilty or guilty or
not guilty not guilty swallows cries I
did not lock those living up in my truck
that's an 18-wheeler coming gotcha now I
know hey everyone I hope you guys enjoy
this episode of just candid news if you
guys want to submit some articles check
in the description below or send it at
WWE
you are Elcom slash just kidding news
the link is right underneath also follow
us on twitter at JK films or instagram @
JK films order facebook at just kidding
films all the links are down below right
now dad and right on the left is our
last video go ahead and click it yeah
what if it's like Ron Jeremy and like an
average looking woman I'm looking at the
girl ha ha so what did the guy get just
kind of a prison or was it just random
people [__] no they both these two
actually just left the strip club
awesome yeah the shirt clubs
strip club doesn't either so a couple a
guy in a guard yeah I know girl oh man
ago I just let this hubby to buddies
just left the strip club and an eye out
for - me - lets beat you
love the ship club had sex outside it
was in front of a jail and it caused a
massive chocolate jam and now they're
being charged for indecent exposure and
disorderly conduct right next to it jail